porque representa en términos de
seguridad europea para la otan la
invitación a finlandia y suecia
bueno definitivamente termina de cerrar
el cerco geográfico del cual para el
caso de finlandia pues había mantenido
una neutralidad por mucho tiempo y yo
creo que ya prácticamente muchas de las
naciones que son tienen frontera natural
con la federación de rusia y ya son
parte ya van a ser parte de la otan en
este caso digamos en suecia y finlandia
y finlandia que la que comparte una
frontera de 1300 kilómetros pues
prácticamente ya es el caso finlandia
pues cierre ese cerco geográfico a
excepción de gamos un poco más al sur de
lo que es europa oriental pues el caso
de bielorrusia y ucrania el caso de
ucrania pues publicación que hizo rusia
y acaso bielorrusia que se mantiene como
un aliado estratégico de rusia en la
cual el presidente alexander lukashenko
pues mantiene digamos de esa esa
condición de aliado pero prácticamente
desde los países bálticos que son los
que comparten frontera natural también
con la federación de rusia y ahora
finlandia yo creo que ahora se completa
prácticamente este esta noción
un resguardo geográfico más amplio por
parte de la otan bueno cuáles son los
pasos a seguir ahora
bueno lo que viene ahora es más uno de
los más complicados sin duda fue el veto
que estaba poniendo turquía yo creo que
ahora prácticamente con esta liberación
del veto en la que turquía pues accede a
que finlandia y suecia se incorporen
formalmente porque
parecer parte de la otan se requiere
digamos del voto unánime desde como uno
que se oponga prácticamente se cierra
esa posibilidad ahora que turquía ya
aceptó levantar el veto yo creo que lo
que viene ahora son cuestiones más de
carácter administrativo porque de todas
maneras suaves y finlandia ya venían
participando desde el punto de vista
militar con la otan en distintos en
distintas operaciones militares que era
como muy común que ocurra eso en europa
y ahora lo que viene son cuestiones
administrativas que terminan de dar este
la agresión ya formal a finlandia y
suecia como parte de la otan bueno rusia
ya ha venido criticando a la otan en
medio de estas medidas que se están
tomando en medio de la cumbre pero
podríamos esperar algunas represalias
bueno la preocupación está en que ahora
que ahora y podemos haber 1800
kilómetros de frontera que ahora van a
ser parte de la otan por ponerlo digamos
en estos términos simbólicos yo creo que
va a haber mucha presión por parte de
rusia en esta frontera con finlandia a
pesar de que ya hay putin había dicho en
algún momento que no requería digamos de
un enfrentamiento con con finlandia pero
el tema de ucrania de alguna manera pues
pone en vilo que cualquier cosa digamos
a través de la frontera en el caso con
los países bálticos que pertenecen desde
hace muchos años a la otan y ahora con
finlandia pues podría esperarse que
cualquier cosa puede llegar a ocurrir
sobre todo porque se ha venido
incrementando la atención con el ex
clave de kaliningrado que está digamos
dentro de la dentro de entre polonia y
lituania se ha venido incrementando una
situación de atención en donde lituania
pues ha recibido cierto tipo de amenazas
por parte de buscar